matsche pampe für matlab das wacken open
air 2015 versinkt im schlamm aber kein
sturz wichtig dagegen laute musik und
gute stimmen
wacken das ist ein spielplatz für
erwachsene
wir sind hier weil es wichtig ist sich
ab und zu aber gehen zu lassen einfach
mag es einfach spaß freiheit als kind
wollte ich schon mitspielen und jetzt in
meinem alter sehe ich hier mit
unter den headlinern in diesem jahr der
gruselrocker rob zombie aus den usa
auch die berliner mittelalter-rocker in
extremo mischen mit
ja
schon erst mal hierhin eingeladen zu
werden und einfach der professionellste
schweinestall die man kennt so einfach
geil
eine ungewöhnliche kollaboration judo
treten gemeinsam mit dem musikkorps der
bundeswehr auf die soldaten ein
einmaliges erlebnis die metal-band
hingegen war schon oft hier
als band man macht ja auch business ist
natürlich schon wichtig
wacken spielen viele leute immer wenn
die 80.000 leuten spielen macht man auch
nicht jeden tag
unglaubliches erlebnis total
elektrisierend hier wird einmal im jahr
eine stadt um ein dorf gebaut und das
ist toll dabei zu sein
wacken in schleswig-holstein das 2000
seelen dorf liegt einen großteil des
jahres im dornröschenschlaf jeden august
fallen seit den 90er jahren tausende
metalheads ein und verwandeln das nest
in eine pilgerstätte
die dorfbewohner machen gute geschäfte
mit den besuchern und kennen deren
rituale ganz genau wenn sie kommt schön
wenn sie wieder gehen
noch ist das wacken open air in vollem
gang
der laudes silence aus bosnien treten
diesmal beim musikwettbewerb metal
battle gegen nachwuchs bands aus 27
weiteren ländern an
vor 26 jahren haben ein paar freunde aus
wacken das festival aus liebe zum heavy
metal gegründet mittlerweile kommen
jährlich mehr als 75.000 fans schon ein
jahr im voraus sind die karten
ausverkauft für 170 euro pro ticket
das viertägige festival ein
kommerzieller mega erfolg der zeitraum
ist verkehrt die lage ist erkennt alles
ist völlig verkehrt aber wir sind hier
aufgewachsen und dass unser heimat und
wir wollten metal festival machen und
dann haben wir hier angefangen und jetzt
machen wir immer weiter traditionen
werden hier hochgehalten und so sind
auch die jedes jahr am start die kapelle
der wackener feuerwehr
das festival ist berühmt für seine
musikalische toleranz
nirgendwo sonst auf der welt treffen so
viele menschen aufeinander und werden
freunde
hier wird man mit offenen armen
empfangen